Okay
Ach Leute, mal kurz bisschen lüften hier
Lüftchamp
Das machen wir heute gar nicht
Heute machen wir das übliche, was wir sonntags morgens immer machen
Genau, Level Capture Bait
Oder was in der Richtung
Kurz in die Business Mails gucken
Ach, ist das heute?
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum es den gibt
Ich hab von all diesen Sachen keinen Plan
Irgendwas Christliches auf jeden Fall
Was?
Wie?
Kein Mailer?
Oh, Anti-Cheat mehr
Wahrscheinlich wollte es keiner mehr spielen damit
Okay
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die mit dieser Spieleanzahl, wenn die nicht super
krass rein cashen alle, da irgendwie langfristig was machen können, naja, mal gucken.
Ja, aber selbst wenn es rauskommt, glaube ich nicht, dass ich das großartig, mal gucken,
ob es überhaupt jemals aus der Beta rauskommt.
So, ich bin echt noch ein bisschen, ach komm mal, hier gibt es Trends, hier wurden gerade
Trends angezeigt.
Warum werden die Trends all hier?
Schlagt den Star Sieger, who cares.
Italien, Deutschland, juckt mich nicht.
Pink Star.
Was ist das denn?
Who cares, Italien, Deutschland, juckt mich nicht, pinkste Bedeutung, irgendwas christliches.
Iron Man, Hamburg, alles uninteressant, das einzige, was mich interessieren würde, ist
immer noch, warum dieser Zug umgekippt ist, ist ja entscheidend noch nichts rausgekommen.
Ich meine, Züge kippen normalerweise nicht einfach um, jetzt stellt euch doch mal wirklich
vor, ihr fahrt nie Zug und ihr kauft euch ein 9 Euro Ticket und dann seid ihr in einem
Zug der Umfeld, in dem ihr normalerweise nie drin gewesen werdet, also das war richtig
scheiße oder?
Stimmt, aber soll ich dir mal was sagen, ich hab immer montags frei, mir bringt das
überhaupt nichts.
Ich muss mal kurz was gucken, Feiertage Hessen, wie siehts denn, wie siehts denn aus, wann
kommt denn wieder was?
26, das hier ist Vatertag, ne, also Moment, das ist ja schon vorbei, das hier haben wir
als nächstes, 16, da muss ich Urlaub nehmen, unbedingt, also hier, 17, da, sehts ist richtig,
Tag der Deutschen Einheit ist auch wieder montags, Alter, kann das nicht mal, hätten
wir uns nicht mal irgendwie einen Tag später vereinigen können, Gatschi-Buzz, was soll
das, Montag, da bringt mir ja gar nichts, und danach erst wieder an Weihnachten, oh das
liegt ja mega beschissen, Alter, boah liegt Weihnachten dieses Jahr kacke, guckt mal,
24 ist Samstag, Feiertage ist Sonntag und Montag, da hab ich ja gar nichts von, das
ist ja mal hardcore, das ist ja mal ultra beschissen, Alter, Samstag, Sonntag, Montag,
dann ist Silvester, dann ist Silvester wahrscheinlich auch am Sonntag, ne, Alter, das ist ja mal
hardcore beschissen, ich finde man sollte das so regeln, dass Weihnachten nie auf Feiertage
fallen darf, also nie auf freie Tage fallen darf, warum, bist du Friseur, ne, was hat
das mit Friseur zu tun, ja so Friseur, weil Friseur montags zu haben, ne, aber ich bin
montags auch nicht auf der Arbeit, das heißt, wenn das so ist, Samstag frei, Sonntag normal
frei, Montag normal auch frei, das heißt, ich krieg im Prinzip nichts extra durch Weihnachten,
ne, dann brauch ich Weihnachten auch nicht, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, dass
die vor ein paar Monaten diesen, diesen, die wollten noch so einen Corona, einen einmaligen
Corona Feiertag oder irgendwie sowas einführen, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wo sie
gesagt haben, die Leute sollen daheim bleiben und sonst wie was, da war ich sofort dafür,
warum ist mir egal, daheim bleiben ist gut, der 24, 26 soll nie auf, ja, der soll nie
auf Tage fallen, die normalerweise auch so frei wären, das wäre doch am besten, im
Zweiten muss man halt ein bisschen im Dezember die Tage kürzen und überspringen, das ist
ja mal so schwer, so schwer sollte das jetzt ja nicht sein, ne, dann lassen wir beispielsweise
den, den dritten Dezember weg oder so und dann, dann können wir den 24. Dezember dann am Donnerstag
machen und sowas, das find ich gut.
Die, den, den Folina exploit, äh, ich, warum? Also ich glaub, irgendwie super krasse Erkenntnis
haben wir dann da auch nicht, wir führen im Endeffekt irgendeinen Python-Skript aus
und dann geht der Windows-Calculator auf, glaube ich standardmäßig war es, beziehungsweise
ne, ja, ja doch.
Ich glaube, dass es keine solche Regel gibt, ach ne, ach ne, da wäre ich jetzt gar nicht
drauf gekommen, dass so eine Regel nicht gibt, aber ich hätte gerne so eine Regel, ich mein,
wir sind doch mittlerweile so schnell dabei, äh, bei allem, was einem nicht gefällt zu
sagen, das muss man regeln und verbieten, dann können wir doch auch mal sowas regeln
und verbieten, oder, ich mein, wenn das eigentlich eine sinnvolle Sache ist, dann lässt man halt
mal den ersten oder zweiten Dezember weg, man macht quasi einen Reverse, ähm, Februar,
Februar lässt man am Ende was weg, im Dezember lässt man einfach am Anfang was weg, so,
dass dann nie auf freie Tage fällt, das Weihnachten, dass man tursichtliche freie Tage hat, neue
LSD-Videos an, wir gucken uns die LSD-Videos an, ja, ich weiß, dass da keine Regelung gibt,
wie gesagt, ähm, normalerweise ist ja auch relativ balance, hast du schon recht, aber
trotzdem, interessiert mich nicht, will das, will das man frei hat an Weihnachten, zusätzlich.
Was, jemand hatte neuerdings eine Idee, Feiertage am Wochenende nachzuholen, die Briten machen
das, was?
Nee, die, die machen das nicht, oder, ich mein, wenn Feiertag in die Woche fällt, dann
wird der auch gemacht.
Ach, so meinst du das?
Ja, so, das, so müsste das sein, ja, so müsste das sein, genauso, genauso Leute, genauso,
wenn es auf ein Wochenende fällt, dann wird es nachgeholt in der Woche an einem Werktag,
genauso müsste man das machen, aber das wäre wahrscheinlich zu Steuerzahler freundlich,
wobei das ja gar nicht mal stimmt, wenn man sich überlegt, ähm, wo, wo die richtig viele
Kohle sitzt, ist es wahrscheinlich lieber, die Leute gehen arbeiten, ähm, das wäre zu
bürgerfreundlich, wahrscheinlich das so zu machen bei uns, ja, gut, am Montag, wenn es
am Montag nachgeholt wird, bin ich jebaited, ja, das stimmt, das habe ich gelitten, dann,
aber ich hätte, ich hätte sonst auch gelitten, weil es am Wochenende ist, also es macht eigentlich
keinen Unterschied.
Hast du schon das neue Video, Verlohnt sich das gesehen, vom Programmierer, ja, hab ich
schon, haben wir uns schon angeguckt, der hat einen entspannten Eindruck gemacht, hat gesagt,
der verdient mehr Kohle, als er je braucht, da habe ich gesagt, ja, so muss es sein, eigentlich
müssten das alle, ja, genau, der vier Stunden, dieses Pop-Up, aber je nachdem, was da alles
dran hängt, programmiert er ja nicht, das habe ich am Anfang auch so, das hast du zwar
schon gesagt, aber er programmiert nicht zwangsläufig vier Stunden an dem Hilfe-Button, sondern
an allen Prozessen und Abläufen drum herum, von irgendwelchen Design-Dokumenten bis irgendwelche
Tester, die das testen müssen und so, also, kann ich schon verstehen.
Coding with Floats until I go completely insane, okay, Floats ist Pains-Champ, weil, genau,
wenn ich das hier schon sehe in der Vorschau, ja, 0.1 plus 0.2 muss nicht 0.3 ergeben, das
ist so, auch in Floats, aber nur bis zu einer gewissen Precision, also sprich, ab einem
gewissen Nachkommastelle, stimmt das nicht mehr, das ist genauso, wie wenn man sagt,
okay, in Float 0.9 plus 0.1 gleich gleich 1, das ist auch nicht unbedingt so in Floats,
dafür sind Floats relativ schnell zur Alternative, ja, ich meine, die Alternative ist, wenn du
was hast, was beispielsweise nicht in ein normales Int reinpasst, und du brauchst halt Nachkommastellen,
was heißt so mal, was laber ich für ein Schwachsinn, wenn du was hast, wo du Nachkommastellen brauchst,
und da musst du was wie Big Int oder sowas nehmen, oder irgendwie was in der Richtung,
was unter der Haube irgendwelche Strings verwendet, das ist halt langsam, aber Floats sind halt
immer, Ints sind schneller, aber Floats sind auch relativ geschwind, dafür nimmt man halt
in Kauf, dass es Rundungsprobleme und Genauigkeitsprobleme gibt.
Was verdient ein Wirtschaftsprüfer, ne, das gucken wir nicht, wir gucken uns heute an,
was verdient ein Klempner oder sowas, was hatten die glaube ich noch, das habe ich
schon offen.
Lohnt sich Programmierer-Video, das habe ich geguckt, na Leute, ich muss mal kurz einen
Bonbon lutschen.
Auch das neue, ah es gibt noch eins, es gibt noch ein neueres, ne den da, den haben wir
schon geguckt.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, wenn man das richtig macht, kann man heute in vielen Handwerkernberufen
richtig gut leben, ich meine es ist gefragt als Fuck, und es ist da auch so, die suchen
händeringend Leute, und die müssen dementsprechend, wenn sie die Leute auch haben wollen, das
ordentlich bezahlen, ich meine nicht überall wahrscheinlich, so wie immer, aber so immer
mehr als weniger, also immer öfters, mach was mit Holz, ai ai ai, Bonkers, Banken arbeiten
mit anderen Datentypen, ne, nicht unbedingt, Banken haben in der Regel halt ein, was ist
das Decimal ist es in sich hab, also ein 128-Spit, 128-Spit, ein 128-Spit Datentyp glaube ich,
ich bin jetzt gerade nicht sicher, ob es 128-Spit ist, ja, ja, ja, so was gucken wir uns
an, also 16-Bit, das sind 128-Spit, das reicht in der Regel 28-29 Stellengenauigkeit, gestern
war ein Programmierer-Clip auf LSF, was ist LSF, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was,
was, was, was, was bin ich hier sehen Chat?
Das ist doch kein Urlinshort noch.
Der returnt einfach den gleichen Kram immer wieder.
Wo ist, was ist daran geschortet?
Ach so das ist ja gut du kannst näher wirklich shorter ist es jetzt nicht ok denn denn das verstehe ich jetzt nicht
Ach die Tests waren Trash ach so okay das geht jetzt für mich aus dem Kontext nicht hervor aber okay ja
Ja das war ja klar dass der chat wieder auf das programming grill ansprengt
Was sonst? Also was schauen wir uns heute an?
Zeig mal hier
Was sagt denn mein Ikea Feinstaubsensor? Moment das muss ich kurz checken ist jetzt hier alles in Ordnung drin
Feinstaubsensor nicht wirklich zu viel Feinstaub
Okay Leute also LevelCaptureBate komm wir lassen uns eine Runde LevelCaptureBate 8 Minuten okay was hat er denn heute für uns? Battle of 9 please
Reveal Date liegt jetzt werden schon die Daten geleakt wo etwas angekündigt wird was 6 Monate verschoben wurde
Na das ist aber mal ein also das kann man sich ja gar nicht behalten so viel Geleake ist da und man könnte auch sagen Battlefield 2042 Season 1 Reveal Date es interessiert noch ungefähr 1500 Leute wenn überhaupt Sekunde wo wir gerade dabei sind New World
Battlefield okay immerhin 3000 Spieler peak noch hier ging es aber ganz schön rauf meine Güte also RIP und New World okay New World hat es jetzt tatsächlich unter 20k geschafft so verkackt man
Krass Alter ich glaube es ist die heftigste Spielerzahlen Vernichtung die ich je gesehen habe von knapp einer Million auf 20k bald werden Leaks geleakt oh guck mal da McDonalds Puff Breakfast alles klar warum auch immer
Okay LevelCaptureBate uns
Ein Reveal Trailer wird bald Revealed das ist cool
Okay LevelCapture Schieß los wer sonst wer sonst
Ja nix nix eine Map ein Specialist und paar Kleinkram nix absolut lächerlich
Das ist natürlich was Battlefield 2042 Stringen gebraucht hat mehr Helis
Das ist die Idee dass man jetzt auch mal die Portal Maps für was sinnvolles verwendet haben wir ganz davon abgesehen wie wäre es mal mit neuem Portal Content
Das ist gut jetzt mal ernsthaft wie kann es ein Revealed Date sein wenn man schon das Revealed hat also man weiß es ja schon dass es das ist und man sieht Ausschnitte daraus also wie kann man ein Revealed Date Revealen mit was was schon Revealed ist
Ich blinke mittlerweile nicht mehr durchaus jetzt fehlt bloß noch dass es geleakt wird
Stell euch mal vor es wird geleakt wann das Revealed Date Revealed wird mit was was eigentlich schon Revealed ist
Dann ist vorbei und dann muss drauf Reacted werden und am besten Reacted dann noch eine auf die Reaction dann sind wir komplett
Was der Programmierer aus dem Video hatte ein 6 Jahre altes Video von dir in seinen Favoriten tatsächlich ja
Welcher davon witzig und welches Video ja gut wahrscheinlich ein Battlefield oder so
Das wird auch nie fertig aber immerhin im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Scam Games CSGO Pro wurde gefolgt aha ja sowas kann ich mich dran erinnern habe ich mal aufgenommen
Im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Games die auch ganz viel Kohle bekommen haben und nichts damit auf die Reihe bekommen die machen ja wenigstens was also man kann nicht sagen dass Star Citizen ein Scam Game ist
Fertig wird es wahrscheinlich trotzdem nie oder was heißt fertig so in dem Zustand wo man sagen würde okay man lässt jetzt die ganze Welt drauf los
Moment die bekommen die bekommen immer noch mehr Geld okay das hätte ich nicht gedacht warum mich hätte eigentlich gedacht die Leute haben Vertrauen darin verloren aber anscheinend nicht anscheinend sind die Leute zufrieden mit dem was man sieht
Also wie gesagt ich bin auch der Mann das ist kein Scam in dem Sinn ja Scams hast du heute Kickstarter Scams sowas hast du ja in allen Ecken ich bin immer noch etwas traurig dass Camelot Unchained nichts wurde
Ich mein ich hab den Kram gebacked für irgendwie 200 Euro für Beta Access und sowas in dem Spiel tut sich gar nichts und die haben letztens also die veröffentlichen immer noch Newsletter aber es ist komplett lächerlich
Und letztens haben die allen Ernst man muss sagen das Spiel ist auch seit irgendwie sieben Jahren oder so in der Entwicklung und die haben letztens ein Newsletter gepostet dass sie jetzt ein neues Köchersystem implementieren
Dass wenn du eine Bogenklasse spielst dass dann wenn du den Pfeil verbraucht hast automatisch was wieder einer in den Köcher kommt da hab ich mir gedacht Moment was das sind legit 5 Zeilen Code darüber schreibt dir ein Newsletter bei einem Spiel was irgendwie sieben Jahre Verzögerung hat
Da hat sie uns alles Bullshit
Also ich fand sowohl Pathfinder Kingmaker als auch Wrath of the Righteous ziemlich gut beide haben ein Problem Kingmaker und Wrath of the Righteous das letzte Viertel ist nicht gut also hat ganz weird champ pacing weird champs Story die unfertig wirkt und also das letzte Viertel ist nicht nicht gut
Bei beiden der Rest ist aber richtig Pock
Man kann man kann es ja auch übertreiben mit Titellängen oder Total War Warhammer 3 Blablabla Blablabla das ist ein Titel da brauchst du eine Seite für um allein das overflowed wahrscheinlich die Steam Hatter Box
Ich glaube es ist ein Spiel was fast auf noch mehr Plattformen rausgekommen ist als Skyrim
Das gab es ja überall Playstation 2, Wii, Wii U, wahrscheinlich Switch, PC, PS, Things, Bombs, also meine Güter
Okay oder Remaken die das richtig also Remaken die das wie Resident Evil 2 und Resident Evil 3 das wäre natürlich ja sieht es sieht so aus wenn man sich das im Hintergrund anguckt das ist kein kein wir porten das mal wieder neu sondern ich glaube es klappt Resident Evil 4 das original gab es sogar auf dem Handy mittlerweile
Die machen das im Stile von dem 2er und 3er Remaker das ist nicht schlecht
Tja hat hat jemand von euch eine Ahnung ob Steam Deck jetzt erfolgreich war ist oder nicht
Ich habe da ja so meine Zweifel ob das so gut angekommen ist wie man erhofft hat ist es ich weiß es nicht
Der Friseur war großer PS Vita Fan
Kann ich mich gar nicht mehr verwahren das
Das wissen wir
Es gab ja es gab ja schon irgendwelche Gerüchte aber mal gucken was er jetzt sagt
Kindergarten
Was ist
Was los Chat
Was ist was habe ich verpasst
War irgendwas im Video
Achso wir haben ein Video von ihm oh nein Monka es naja gut was willst du machen
Wenn es danach geht wenn es danach geht was du in YouTube Videos so siehst das kannst du ja im Vorfeld nicht wissen
Was ist das
Was habe ich das richtig verstanden
Ja das habe ich auch gesehen da wusste ich nicht so genau was ich damit anfangen soll aber ich bin auch kein richtig krasser Sonic Fan also ich male keine Sonic Characters und ich cosplaye auch keine Sonic Characters und ich gucke auch kein rule 34 Sonic Characters
Was ist das